>> Greg: AS AMERICA STRUGGLES
WITH COVID, RISING CRIME AND
RIOTS, IT’S NICE AT THE TEACHERS
UNIONS ARE HELPING OUT.
I KID.
AND THEIR DEMANDS FOR REOPENING
SCHOOLS, THE UNITED TEACHERS OF
L.A., THEY ARE, SURPRISE,
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
NOW THESE GO BEYOND WHAT NORMAL
UNIONS DEMAND, WORSE THAT THEY
USE THIS CRISIS TO PRESERVE
THEIR POWER BY DESTROYING THOSE
WHO CONFORM, BY TRYING TO SHUT
DOWN CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THEY
ARE DEMANDING THE OMISSION OF
ANY COMPETITION AND DEPRIVING
DESPERATE FOR FAMILIES OF AN
EDUCATION.
THIS SPEAKS TO THE REAL TRUTH OF
THE NORTH AMERICAN PROBLEM, IT’S
NOT SYSTEMIC RACISM BUT
SYSTEMICALLY CORRUPT EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
IT’S THE TEACHERS UNION, WHOSE
ONLY GOAL IS TO CANCEL
COMPETITION THAT MIGHT REVEAL
THEIR INCOMPETENCE.
SO AT THE START OF LIFE FOR
STUDENTS ARE PLACED IN THE
SYSTEM WHERE NO MATTER HOW MANY
BILLIONS, AND THIS UNION PREFERS
IT THAT WAY.
WE DON’T LIKE YOU WOULD THINK
THAT WOULD BE EMBRACED BUT THE
PRICE OF UNION SUCCESS IS
STUDENT FAILURE.
THAT WE REALIZE THAT BECAUSE OF
ALL OUR INEQUALITIES IS THE
SCANDALOUS LACK OF CHOICES.
AND AT LEAST FOR THEIR FUTURES.
SO HOW CAN A UNION MAKE THESE
DEMANDS?
>> I THINK PARTLY IS THE UNIONS
ARE NOT SERVING THE TEACHERS AND
UNIONS WELL.
THIS IS PROBABLY NOT THE TIME TO
DO AN EXERCISE IN OVERREACH
BECAUSE YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HAD TO RETHINK EVERYTHING.
MAYBE HOW THEY LIVE, AND HOW
THEY EDUCATE THEIR KIDS.
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS INCLUDING
I BELIEVE DOWN IN MIAMI, THEY
ARE SWITCHING SCHOOLS BACK AND
STARTING LATER, THEY WILL START
ONLINE AND THEY WILL TRY TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET IN THE
CLASSROOM.
I THINK PEOPLE GENERALLY WANT
THEIR KIDS IN SCHOOL BUT THEY
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT SAFETY.
HOWEVER ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THIS IS ALSO DOING IS MAKING
PEOPLE THINK ABOUT HOW THEY
EDUCATE THEIR KIDS AND NECESSITY
IS THE MOTHER OF INVENTION.
YOU THINK, MAYBE I COULD TRY AT
A DIFFERENT WAY.
YOU START TO SEE THE POSSIBILITY
OF EITHER HOMESCHOOLING OR
PEOPLE GETTING TOGETHER.
THAT MIGHT LEAVE BEHIND, AND
THAT’S A VERY REAL CONCERN, THE
LOWER INCOME STUDENTS THAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT.
SO THAT HAS TO BE A
CONSIDERATION AND I THINK THAT
THIS PANDEMIC WILL CHANGE THE
WAY THAT SOME PARENTS DECIDE TO
TEACH THEIR KIDS AT HOME.
>> Greg: JUAN, WHAT COULD BE
THEIR LEGITIMATE DEFENSE OF
WANTING TO DEFUND CHARTER
SCHOOLS?
>> Juan: OF CHARTER SCHOOLS,
AND I THINK IN GENERAL, AND
THAT’S THE OPTION TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE, AND THOSE ARE KIDS IN
BETTER NEIGHBORHOODS GET BETTER
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY GET MORE IN
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING AND MORE
PARENTAL SUPPORT.
JUST PICKING UP ON WHAT DANA WAS
SAYING, ONE OF THE ISSUES HAS TO
BE IF YOU HAVE INNOVATION AND
THE LIKE, OFTEN TIMES I SAY THIS
WITH A SAD HEART, KIDS COMING
FROM SINGLE-PARENT FAMILIES
WHERE THE MOM MAY BE AN
ESSENTIAL WORKER OR A LOW INCOME
WORKER AND NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT KIND OF PERSONAL
INTERACTION DURING THE DAY.
DOES THAT CHILD THEREFORE GET
LEFT BEHIND?
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN ME.
I THINK OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN
IMAGINE HOW I FEEL AND ON THE
BIG SCHOOL CHOICE PERFORMING PRO
EVEN PEOPLE WHO FEEL LIKE THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW JERSEY,
BILL GATES, NOBODY’S HARD-LINE
CONSERVATIVE, THESE PEOPLE,
EVERYBODY WANTS SCHOOLS OPEN AND
IT’S JUST A MATTER OF DOING IT
SAFELY.
PARENTS ARE HARDWIRED TO PROTECT
THEIR CHILDREN AND TEACHERS
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A STAKE IN THIS.
WE HAVE TO WORK ON IT BUT WE
WILL FIND A WAY.
>> Greg: SPEAKING OF WHICH I
THINK WE HAVE TAPES OF
BILL GATES.
>> I AM A BIG BELIEVER THAT
YOUNG CHILDREN, THE BENEFITS IN
ALMOST EVERY LOCATION, AS YOU
GET UP TO AGE LIKE 13 OR HIGHER
THEN YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT YOUR
LOCALE TO DECIDE WHAT YOU WILL
DO WITH HIGH SCHOOLS.
THEN YOU HAVE TO PUT MASSIVE
EFFORT IN THERE TO BE CONTINUE
LEARNING ONLINE.
>> THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR, OUR
KIDS NEED TO BE IN SCHOOL.
THEY WILL DEFINITELY BE IN THE
CLASSROOM.
>> EVERY EDUCATION EXPERT WOULD
SPOKEN TO OVER THE PAST THREE
MONTHS HAS CONFIRMED THAT IN
PERSON EDUCATION IS CRITICAL.
WE MUST TRY TO INCLUDE AT LEAST
SOME ASPECT OF IN PERSON
EDUCATION FOR OUR CHILDREN THIS
FALL.
>> Greg: KATIE, FEEL FREE TO
EITHER DISCUSS THAT OR THE
UNIONS, YOUR PICK.
>> Katie: THAT’S THE
SCIENTIFIC PATH THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD BE FOLLOWING BUT ON THE
UNION SIDE IT’S DESPICABLE THAT
THEY ARE PUTTING THIS LAUNDRY
LIST OF DEMANDS INTO THE FUTURE.
THEY ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT THEM
AND PRETEND TO CARE ABOUT THEM.
THAT’S A REASON WHY A LOT OF
TEACHERS AROUND THE COUNTRY HAVE
ACTUALLY SUED THEIR GOVERNMENTS,
BECAUSE THEY DON’T WANT TO BE
PART OF A POLITICAL PARTY AND
PAY DUES TO THOSE UNIONS WHEN
THEY DON’T HAVE THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE KIDS IN MIND.
IN TERMS OF GETTING RID OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS, AND FORCE THEM
TO DO BETTER, THEY JUST WANT TO
BE PAID FOR DOING THEIR JOBS AND
THEY WANT TO HOLD KIDS HOSTAGE
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME THIS
KEEPS GOING ON.
>> Greg: JESSE, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE AMERICAN TEACHERS
FEDERATION WILL BE ON THE DAILY
BRIEFING TOMORROW TO DISCUSS
THIS.
I ASSUME YOU WILL BE TUNING IN
TO WATCH IT?
>> Jesse: AS ALWAYS.
ALSO GREG, DID YOU DRESS LIKE A
MIDDLE SCHOOL MATH TEACHER TO DO
THIS MONOLOGUE?
MONOLOGUE?
HONEST-TO-GOODNESS.
DO YOU HAVE SWEAT STAINS HERE,
TOO?
YOU ALSO HAVE GLASSES AND A
SWEATER.
THIS WAS A SOCIAL JUSTICE
SHAKEDOWN.
WHO WROTE THE DEMANDS, OMAR?
THIS IS FANATICAL STUFF.
I THINK THEY ARE THE MOST
HARD-CORE UNION OUT THERE BUT I
CAN’T SAY ANYTHING MEAN ABOUT
THEM BECAUSE I WILL BE ATTACKED
FOR GOING AFTER TEACHERS.
I JUST KNOW THAT TRUMP SENT THEM
100 BILLION AND I HOPE THAT
WINDS UP IN THE RIGHT HANDS AND
NOT IN THE POCKETS OF SOME
ADMINISTRATORS.
I HOPE THAT GOES TO THE RIGHT